نحن على كل حال سالنا الناس انطلاقا
محاوله تبني فكره منح الموظفين اجازات
الطلاق
ما هي الاجازات الاخرى التي يحتاج اليها
الموظف وغير متاحه
او مناسبه نعطي عليها اجازه المفروض
المدراء يصيروا يفكروا الطريقه يتفهموا
الموظفين اكثر
يعرفوا متى لازم ينعت الموظف اجازه
على طلعه يغير جو يعمل استجمام عشان
يستجمع قوه يقدر ينجز اكثر فبيكون ادائه
افضل هذه الاجازات منسيه عندنا نحن يعني
حدا من الفريق عنده امتحان حدا عنده ظرف
عائلي احد عنده كذا انا بصراحه ما بوثق
باعتمد على التعامل الانساني بشكل موظف
يعني انجازات متاحه له يعني له سنه 14 يوم
اكثر من هيك حرام يعني
ضغط الشغل لازم يكون في جزات يعني انه
الواحد يقدر يروح يريح شوي ويرجع يتابع
شغله يعني
بجوز يومين ثلاثه من الطلاق
والله فكره حلوه
الموظف بكون تعبان نفسيا مضغوط
ممكن احتاج هذه الاجازه ممكن ما اقدر
تعبان هو
بحاجه يكون يعطل عن شغله